Dylan, great job on the
"30 Ways to Know You're 20
Pounds Overweight" article.
I heard most girls were
crying by number seven.
All right, next
order of shizz,
We're still 80 tips
away from being done
with 500 hottest
sex tips.
Start pitching.
What if, while you're going down
on him you take a feather
and you gently tickle the
space behind his balls?
Hunter, it's sex tips
to drive him wild,
not drive him mild.
(laughing)
That's hilarious, did you
guys hear what I said?
(all laughing)
Okay, write that down.
Actually, just put
it right on the blog.
I don't want people
to have to wait for that.
Okay, Lenore, go.
So you dress like
a Boy Scout
but only from the
bottom down
and then you sit on
his knee and queef.
Interesting,
I like it... more.
Take a five-hour
energy
and pour it inside
your vagina
right before you
have sex.
Where's your office?
I'm moving it
closer to mine.
Spin me around.
What if you take
a pumice stone
and you hold it over an open
flame for like an hour
and then you
gently grate it
up and down
his shaft?
Wow, love it.
Okay, guys, we need
75 more and don't be lazy.
So far, the pumice
stone's my favorite.
You put his penis
in a glory hole.
You begin to stroke it.
You take a
mouthful of cum
from his three
best friends
and then you shoot it in his
face until he explodes?
Hmm...
What about a
sawed-off shotgun?
You could take it and
rub it up and down his neck
till he's
super hard.
Okay.
Bridgett.
You look like
a sad emoticon.
Give me something.
Okay, okay,
how 'bout this.
You fall in love
with a stockbroker,
you know because it
really seems like
he wants to
get married.
And then you're
together at the
Chipotle and his friends
from work show up,
and he pretends like
you're bussin' the table.
So what do you do?
You pick up his basket,
you clear his table.
You wipe it
and you say,
"Can I get you
anything else?"
And you know
what he says?
He says, "Yeah, could you
freshen our drinks?"
So you freshen
everybody's drinks.
And you go back
into the kitchen.
You take somebody's
card, you clock out,
you go home and then
what do you do?
You pour yourself
a bottle of Chardonnay
and you sit
on the toilet
and then you start playing Words
With Friends with Lenore.
And then you just
go and you get into bed...
And then he explodes.
What's happening
over here?
in this section?
Bridgett is going
through a breakup.
You don't know what
I'm going through.
Okay, she's a
ticking time bomb.
Somebody top
her off.
I'm not hearing
sex tips.
What, are we
hanging out--
are you guys
my friends?
No.
So you wait till he
finds out his dad's
been diagnosed
with prostate cancer.
Then, while he's crying,
you put one finger--
two fingers up
his butt...
until he explodes?
I have one.
Make eye contact?
You're a cunt,
fan me.
How' bout, go to
Trader Joe's,
and buy an Amy's
frozen Indian dinner
Then smear it all
over his genitals
in slow circles
clockwise...
and then counter
clockwise.
I tried that...
and it works.
Okay.
You're fired.
That eye contact thing
was ridic-- get out.
Guys, this article is
gonna cause a baby boom.
We're doing
God's work.
♪♪
2,000 men are suing "Glamo"
Magazine for emotional damages
claiming their sex tips
are at least partially
responsible for the fact
that they were bizarrely
raped by their girlfriends.
( anchorman )
We spoke to one
of the plaintiffs.
I came here today because
I don't want anyone
to ever have to go
through what I went through.
I bet you guys didn't
know that you can, uh,
fit a Hanukkah candle
in your pee-hole.
Well, guess what "Glamo"
Magazine, you can't.
Now I have to
piss in a bag.